all right we are gonna get started I'm
Alexander rose I'm the executive
director here at the long now foundation
and I want to welcome you here how many
people is this their first time at the
interval nice welcome thank you for
coming this series started with the idea
that we are going to be able to do more
intimate talks obviously than the the
larger series that we do down now at SF
jazz but long now started with two ideas
and we really only have been explicit
about one we started with this idea of
the long now which Brian Eno one of our
founding board members coined but
actually he coined it as part of another
thing which he called the big here and
was when he moved when he moved from New
York or from London to New York for the
first time he realized when people in
New York said here if they meant the two
walls that we are between and when they
said now they meant the five minutes
that we are in not the larger here and
the larger now and so Chris not only
being an amazing person I know many of
you know him personally but I think he
has personally expanded the bigger here
for all of us who get to follow him
vicariously or actually on some of his
trips and so I welcome Chris to expand
our here once again
this is awesome I love the long now
I love the interval I love Xander and I
have to say you know as I look out on
this group I'm something strikes me and
for those of you follow my work you know
about my portrait series people I admire
and you know what's interesting is all
of those people are here tonight so I'm
going to do something unusual maybe
never been done before
and that's take a photograph of all of
you from here okay Chris Anderson do
your thing okay
you know that's a that's a memory I'm
gonna treasure because to me memories
are the currency of our lives and this
is a talk about what happens when a
person becomes obsessed with capturing
and sharing those memories a story that
takes place over ten years across 50
countries a story captured in over a
million photographs settle in because
I'm going to show you every single one
of them yeah yeah it's the law now and
my hope is that this story inspires each
of you to journey further geographically
spiritually but most importantly as
documentarians of your own lives the
photographs that matter to me are the
ones that transform an ordinary moment
into a treasured memory that record a
bit of what makes us unique and this is
a unique moment and hopefully create a
photograph that endures this is His
Holiness the Dalai Lama
but photography has another remarkable
property it can transport us into other
lives and other realities it can create
windows into the otherwise unknown this
is a picture I took at the South Pole
just a few weeks ago that's not a lens
effect that's a halo APAR Hylian and a
sundog created by ice crystals so
tonight we're going around the world
compressing a hundred days of exploring
into each minute we'll travel from the
North Pole to the south briefly stopping
in the mid-latitudes diving below our
oceans and above our skies but like most
journeys this one is not linear this is
a photo I took in China exactly but uh
me too photographer was not only the
last thing I imagined I'd be it wasn't
even on the list I grew up on the road
the product of a Greek father an
American mother I lived in so many
places it's hard to keep track and this
is what the new kid in school looks like
shell-shocked
yeah that's quality right there I was
that new kid every few years growing up
that kid who never quite fit in always
the outsider always the observer and
this is the first photo I can remember
taking it's Tokyo in 1987 it could be an
Asia grace if I was lucky I wouldn't
pick up a camera again for another
decade the next 20 years were spent
trying to make it in the Navy my
callsign was Bart by the way like Bart
Simpson maybe you can see why yeah that
is actually Bart on my nametag
good observation and as an entrepreneur
but along the way photography became
more than a hobby it blossomed into an
obsession and in 2008 it became my third
career and the purpose of my life this
obsession was fueled by the ideas of
photographers like Eugene Smith Albert
Watson and Sam Abel especially Sam his
approach to photography would eventually
be the cornerstone of my philosophy to
making images
I'll share a few of those principles
tonight with the hope they do more than
help you decode my photographs that you
might also find them useful in your own
work first and foremost to seek soulful
moments not recreate postcards I call
this photograph of the crush it was
taken in Cusco Peru to compose and wait
for that decisive moment so I have to
say after about three hours on this lead
in Antarctica I was really starting to
question this principle but it worked
out and to make photographs that asked
questions rather than answer them
recognized in the gear doesn't matter
took me a while to figure this one out
but I'm there today but details do a lot
this is obviously Havana to know when
just to be an observer and when to
engage
to seek love wimzie this is Kenya and
Wonder but most importantly to always
say yes to adventure and we've got a lot
of adventuring to do tonight so let's go
big and had 3,600 miles due north to the
north to the South Pole I'm sorry to the
North Pole so if you have a jacket now
might be the time to put it on
I know it's warm in here but it's about
to get cold briefly about the word
arctic you've all heard it before it
literally means near the bear so in the
North we have bears and no penguins and
the opposite is true in Antarctica but
you already knew that you notice that
the Arctic is essentially water
surrounded by land Antarctica on the
other hand is a continent surrounded by
water our journey today will take us to
Franz Josef land the North Pole and fall
bharden they're really only a few
practical ways to the pole by helicopter
by ship by submarine and if you go by
boat there's only one boat that can do
it it's the world's most powerful ship
the nuclear icebreaker 50 years of
victory those aerial shots were done the
old-fashioned way sorry of Chris
Anderson above the ship in a Russian
helicopter it was really great fun but I
have to say a little too much duct tape
for my liking
for real for Murmansk it's a fascinating
four-day journey to the pole empty and
inhospitable except for the toughest
creatures those adapted for life on the
ice I can tell you they scatter when
they see a huge nuclear icebreaker
heading for them unless you're the king
of the Arctic then the ship's just
another possible meal and when they can
smell for miles off and they approach
without fear
in fact there were stories about these
bears coming right to the ship and
pounding on the side of the ship now
that's a pretty brave apex predator the
Arctic is a place of surreal beauty
that's Franz Josef land and
unforgettable colors as you pass 85
degrees north the ice grows thicker and
thicker as you might expect until it
becomes a solid sheet and really the
only way you know you're at the pole is
because your GPS has 90 degrees I know
some of you sticklers out there see that
the GPS doesn't say 90 degrees it says
89 degrees 59 minutes you're right we're
not quite there this is for you it seems
straightforward to get 90 degrees on
your GPS but it is it is not
straightforward I said I was running
around the ship trying to better
well what's at the pole that's a
question I always had well the answer is
nothing
nothing's at the pole nothing but ice
and pressure ridges until someone walks
out with a flag and people get weird
yeah it's pretty interesting to see what
people do when they get to the pole
there's a lot of selfies the North Pole
is difficult and expensive to reach but
not far away at 80 degrees is an equally
beautiful and surprisingly accessible
place in a place I know many of you know
because you've been there and that's
fall bharden here's full Bart's most
well-known feature there's a picture of
it in the back there the global Seed
Vault I'd seen countless pictures of
this Doomsday vault located at the ends
of the earth you've probably seen those
photos but here's a less dystopian view
just in front of this vault and a no
photo you never see is a commercial air
terminal yep this remote High Arctic
community has regular SAS service from
Europe relatively speaking it's a piece
of cake to reach
Arthur Stewart was just there like three
weeks ago does anyone go on that trip
anyway this is downtown long urban
really the only city in Svalbard an
absolutely stunning place especially by
boat
take a moment to imagine what it might
be like to be there experiencing the
deep calm of this vast and lonely place
I'll share a few images without comment
this is a site I won't soon forget
but the Arctic is also a place teeming
with life
who doesn't like the Puffin reindeer
this is a little too close for comfort
they look friendly but they're not that
friendly the reindeer are very friendly
so cute yet humans often struggle to
survive
and sometimes leave altogether this is
the abandoned Soviet mining colony of
pyramidan once a vibrant community
filled with miners and their families
now left to ruin and you see that bust
in the center do you know who that is
some went in one of the eeriest places
on earth
left as it was after the fall of the
Soviet Union with buildings overflowing
with artifacts a pool with no water a
court with no players movie projector
with no film well I guess there is film
but it'd be hard to use my great regret
in this photograph and even being there
was not looking to see what the film was
I could have picked it up and and the
only place on earth where plants look
worse than they do in my apartment not
watered since the 1990s still holds all
the leaves it's incredible being a bit
bipolar in my interests I feel I do feel
obliged to share a few moments from the
places in between
that's Borobudur or in the photograph
there are so many postcard images to
take like the sunset and bug on midnight
in Mongolia
or sunrise in Patagonia nice photographs
but I much prefer images that tell
stories even simple images like this
conversation in Kalama and maar images
that convey feeling
those places are everywhere if you know
how to look humans often transform the
otherwise mundane into the fascinating
this is Moscow but you could take the
same image in New York or San Francisco
people always seem to look the same on
public transportation I don't know and
sometimes you get both humans and
extraordinary environments like this
photograph of cosmonauts heading to
their rocket and Baikonur anyone can
shoot liftoff but it's this next moment
that's way more interesting to me
this is cosmonaut maxim suraev saying
goodbye to his family prior to launch
these are the moments I want to remember
and preserve otherwise stolen forever by
time
like the schoolboy in Kenya this brave
girl in Mongolia nomadic sisters in
Sudan heartfelt moments of serenity like
the sweet girl sitting gracefully in the
streets of Jodhpur a dancer taking a
break in Havana where this point is
makeshift umbrella in the Congo these
men memories matter more than we may
know and like a kind of alchemy they
become more and more meaningful each day
like this recent portrait of my friend
norm Larson sadly norm passed away in
February this is one of the last photos
ever taken of him
some photographic journeys are
meditative like morning Korra and Lhasa
Tibet or late afternoons in Manhattan
this is the best thing I ever got out of
a VC's office is this photograph sorry
well others are just the opposite a
sweet moment in esperance a particularly
rough area in the Democratic Republic of
Congo just a second about this
photograph I was very noticeable in this
town of 50,000 people and it's not clear
to me that it was altogether safe but I
really had some very very special
moments of these people and I felt a
real connection
sometimes it's the animals we remember
like this llama in Cusco Rosana guanaco
I could ever get them straight an
argument for reincarnation right
I mean animal saying something or this
evil in Mongolia or even the world
saddest dog mr. Newman but not
everyone's an enthusiastic subject these
kids can't get away from me fast enough
even the dog is running this is in
Myanmar but mostly people want to engage
occasionally with surprising results
monk let's in Bhutan
can anyone decode these symbols I I
don't know what they're communicating to
me but I was surprised that they did
this sometimes you never really meet
your subjects just capturing a frame in
the movie of their lives I'll forever
wonder about the narrative of this
photograph made in Rajasthan
he looks like he's asking for something
we're about the life of this Berber in
Morocco in many places in the world the
old ways remain two young women starting
their day in the fields of Mandalay the
new world is crowding out the old and
these juxtapositions are endlessly
fascinating like this BMW competing with
the food vendor for space in old Yangon
or camel walk edom it's two concrete
jungle in Giza
but these contrasts even in Instagram
destinations like the Great Pyramid of
Giza or what make life interesting for a
storyteller and if you're willing to go
off the beaten path as Kevin and I were
just saying some truly remarkable places
away like these Nubian pyramids in Sudan
as you can tell by now I'm fascinated
with the far away especially deserts
those both incredibly far away like the
Gobi and those a bit nearer not the Gobi
but my favourite desert of all is the
Crystal desert of Antarctica an
incredibly dry continent covered in ice
ice holding 70% of the world's fresh
water and when you think of Antarctica
think big it's a continent continent 1.5
times the size of the United States a
huge landmass surrounded by the Southern
Ocean and these places in red are the
few of the places we're going to be
visiting today you can see the Antarctic
Peninsula the ailee base station Gould
Bay on the coast and in the center of
this image is the South Pole tourism and
Antarctic is almost entirely by ship
cruising the continents closest point to
South America the Antarctic Peninsula
so probably 99.9% of people this is
where they go when they said they'd go
to Antarctica
a place of epic scale even cruise ships
look tiny where ice comes in countless
shapes and colors
and sometimes even with passengers those
are penguins
arguably it's the most magnificent
coastline in the world and a trip I
couldn't recommend more highly
but for the truly adventurous visiting
Antarctica's wild and remote interior
might be worth considering it's not easy
and almost require always requires the
use of a nice capable aircraft like a
Russian built il-76 here it is landing
at Union glaciers blue ice runway in
January but if you're willing to go
the rewards are significant this is
Mount Rosman
at the base of which is a small tent
camp run by a company called a le
Antarctic antarctic logistics and
expeditions
it's the logistics hub for trips to
Mount Vinson the tallest peak in
Antarctica the South Pole and the
Emperor breeding colony and Gould Bay
it's a five-hour flight from both Punta
Arenas and Chile and the South Pole this
is my home for three weeks in January
it's an interesting thing to have the
Sun never go down the interior is an
immense and empty landscape illuminated
by 24 hours of sunlight as beautiful as
it is dangerous a place of magnificent
desolation utterly devoid of life except
for a few remote camps almost like
extraterrestrial outposts where humans
only survived through extraordinary
effort
depending on a lifeline of food and fuel
from civilization but your proximity to
the extraordinary is unmatched in about
three hours by aircraft you can reach
the emperor colony at Gould Bay if
you're wondering that's a dc-3 from the
1940s the real march of the Penguins a
breeding colony far from shore and away
from where some predators you know the
story
these are royalty among penguins and
they know it
and their cuteness is only surpassed by
the curiosity they seemed especially
interested in those large penguin
newcomers when you approached the colony
the first thing that happens is ten
penguins come right over and it's not
clear what they want but as an aside I
remember leaving on my final day here to
go back on the airplane and two penguins
followed me all the way back to the
airplane when I stopped they stopped and
just looked at me and you just really
wonder what they're thinking it was like
a Disney film but for real if you're
exceptionally intrepid you might head
all the way south to the pole situated
at 9,000 feet it's one of the most
dangerous places on the planet really
getting warmer than 20 below and yes
there is indeed a pole at the pole
you've got two choices for
accommodations the Ritz Carlton or will
would stay and the motel six guess where
I stayed actually that's amundsen-scott
South Pole Station and the le base camp
South Pole camps pretty remarkable place
great food good tents and some of the
most interesting people on earth the
bathrooms aren't too bad it could be a
question for later but bathroom talk is
the number one thing people talk about
in Antarctica everything has to leave so
you could imagine people are taking
great care just hanging around the camp
you might meet people like Robert Swan
the first person to walk to both poles
Yasu agita having just arrived at the
pole after skiing 50 days alone and
unsupported I can assure you he couldn't
be happier to be done I was the first
person to see him and I it was just an
incredible moment there's lots to see at
the pole this is the Dark Sector
astronomy facility it's really like an
alien film
if you ask me it's the perfect set for
stranger things season 3 this is what
happens if you go out without sunscreen
the crystal desert is my favorite place
on earth and to leave is always a
bittersweet moment this is my seventh
trip and I'll keep returning as long as
I live well tonight we've been from the
north to the south but even more remote
in otherworldly places remain like below
the waves with leviathans are the
opportunity to photograph humpbacks in
the Dominican Republic silver Bank for
outside magazine although I love
snorkeling it takes a leap of faith to
jump in the water teeming with huge sea
creatures that Moby Dick moment
but soon that anxiety was replaced by an
incredible sense of tranquility and calm
I began to feel a real connection with
these gentle giants after a few minutes
the mother humpback brought her calf
right to me and it didn't take long
before that baby humpback just started
hanging out
here's Scarlett yes we named her looking
me in the eye and this was taken with a
wide-angle lens this whale is 4 feet 3
feet from me I often wonder where
Scarlett is today hopefully happy and
safe joyfully playing in the ocean's
depths as I mentioned photography has
taken me to places I never imagined and
our final journey tonight is aboard a
u-2 spy plane at the edge of space
probably my most exciting experience as
a photographer I'm going to take you
through a few of the steps that lead up
to a take off and fly prep takes a
better part of a week most of the
instruction is around emergency
procedures and survival this is me in
the hyperbaric chamber they're about to
simulate explosive decompression
so the cabin altitude of the chamber is
going to go from 10,000 feet to 70,000
feet instantaneously causing unprotected
liquids to boil an almost immediate
death for anyone unprotected that's why
I'm in a spacesuit it may look like I'm
totally cool with what's about to
happens but I'm not the morning of the
flight starts with a low residue
breakfast of steak and eggs you guys
remember the Apollo breakfast of steak
and eggs Wow there's a reason it's not
just because they're manly it's because
they don't want any accidents in their
million-dollar space suit you then start
pre breathing pure o2 an hour before the
flight they put you in a treadmill to
accelerate the outgassing of nitrogen a
white van with a lounge chair then takes
you to the aircraft for the launch crew
awaits the Box provide behind me is
providing life-support you can see the
oxygen leaking from the
Tagg a really NASA ask experience there
are many superstitions and rituals in
the YouTube program the first is that
you touch the nose of the aircraft
before flight I'm not normally into this
sort of thing but I was gonna take all
the luck I could get that day you then
salute the plane captain and maintenance
crew and finally you fist bump the pilot
assigned to the chase vehicle here you
see pilot Chris han-shan the chase car
moments before takeoff the u2 is so
difficult to land and take off they have
a Camaro that follows the aircraft
giving commands to the pilots through
the window notice the red landing gear
on the wing that gears gonna fall off on
takeoff reducing the way to the aircraft
you might wonder well then how do you
land the airplane well there's
centreline gear but like a glider the
aircraft tilts over on a titanium wing
spar here we aren't takeoff it's an
incredibly steep climb to altitude
almost vertical and after a bit more
than an hour I was treated to a black
sky and a view of spaceship earth one of
the most profound things I've ever seen
but of all my u2 shots this
unintentional selfie got the most
attention I'm adjusting my GoPro which I
illegally mounted in the YouTube look
it's not hard to look cool in a
spacesuit whoops but you and I both know
the reality right the nerd we've come a
long way together this evening I can't
thank you enough for being such great
travelling companions and I'm gonna lean
on TS Eliot to take us the rest of the
way home he said we shall not cease from
exploration and at the end of all of our
exploring will be to arrive where we
started and know the place for the first
time and for us that San Francisco with
fresh eyes where it often takes more
than rollerskates and a sailor had to
get noticed unless we're paying
attention
notice no one's looking at him but if we
open our eyes in our heart beauty and
love is everywhere no plane trip
required
I'm hoping this evening leaves you
compelled to adventure more deeply to
meet the world head-on with love
compassion and courage to realize it's
never too late to find your calling but
most of all to pursue incredible
memories with unbridled determination so
grab your camera and get out there the
world is waiting for you thank you
[Applause]
Chris thank you so much those I got a
chance to view the deck ahead of time
but going through it with you is it's
truly extraordinary and we're gonna have
questions there's me a mic going around
since we are live casting this please
wait raise your hand and the person with
the mic will get to you I'm just gonna
start off with a few you know Chris
moved through 200 images in about 30
minutes and congratulations
I was I was dubious that that could
happen and I'm a little bit curious I
think you know there's there's not many
people that I run into in the Bay Area
especially in the tech scene that
started their life in the military or
their careers in the military and I'm
just wondering how you got there and
then what was the real impetus for
getting out how did those transitions
work
two words top gun there real well a
little bit for real I thought I wanted
to serve my country maybe an elected
office and I thought maybe being in the
military was a good thing to do and I
was fascinated in it and interested in
the Cold War interested in the Soviet
Union and Top Gun came out it seemed
like a really cool thing to do and I
joined the military and flew p3s as a
navigator and then worked in the
Pentagon and I had a great time a 10 out
of 10 time I loved it and when I worked
in the Pentagon and that's an
interesting experience I worked for that
chief of the Navy Reserve but really the
head of the Navy and when I got there I
mean it's sort of like meeting your
boss's boss's boss you look at them and
if you think well maybe I don't want to
be that person in 30 years
maybe you think there might be something
else and for me there was something else
and so how did that transition work well
how'd you end up in San Francisco okay
question so I was a political sign I'll
of technology but I was a political
science major and interested in Soviet
studies I had zero interest in business
I never read a business book I didn't
look at business publications I have
in the Wall Street Journal and I went to
the University of Illinois so I'm
working in the Pentagon and they have a
program where they'll send lieutenants
to the Kennedy School at Harvard and I
thought well I'm a state school person a
chance to go to Harvard seems like a
cool thing and I applied and
surprisingly got admitted and I ran into
someone who flew the Samer airplanes
that I did and he said you know you
really don't want to go to the Kennedy
School you want to go to the business
club oh my he's like you have many more
options I'm like okay well it seems
recent I thought well if he could get in
maybe I can get into so I applied and
got accepted to the Business School and
it really changed my life but I never
would have considered entrepreneurship
it wasn't even in the kind of lexicon of
my life but Dan Bricklin the founder of
VisiCalc came to class one day and
talked about his journey building things
and it really struck me that that was my
calling
so almost every stage of my life I'd
been surprised at the transition it was
nothing in the plan was anybody hadn't
even considered it well and you
mentioned that you didn't pick up a
camera again until kind of after that
and there was no photography as part of
your Navy career but I real regret of
mine by the way I can't help but think
that the kind of the adventure side of
all of this got a little bit started
yeah well you know you might you might
be angling on one point which is is this
about photography I don't actually think
this is about photography I think this
is about a curiosity in the world and
the photographic life photography is a
byproduct so I think that moving around
a lot with my family traveling around
the world that coded me as a child to
want more of that and I can't get enough
of it I'm happiest you know being
someplace different where every moment
is a new piece of information for me and
that I think everyone's probably
wondering you know you're like you said
to make sure that you always say yes to
adventure but there's you know you also
have to be asked to adventures like
these most of these are invite type
places how do they how do they find I
suspect with your photography their site
they're kind of finding you at this
point but are there ones that you seek
out and as there what's your what's
algorithm for finding these that's a
good question well in the beginning it
started with me signing up for trips if
it sounded like an interesting trip like
to go to Antarctica I went to Antarctica
on a cruise boat I've done it five times
and you know although I'm talking about
going to the South Pole I still
recommend everyone here to do that it's
the only trip I've been on where people
cry at the end of the trip and
photography was pretty good and people
noticed the photography and some people
would say hey do you want to go on this
trip or would you shoot for us and so
that's happened more and more but if I
were to be self-critical
I don't maybe it's cuz I ran a company
before I'd I don't like to ask photo
editors for assignments I like them to
come to me and you know I probably am
missing out on some opportunities
because I you know all good
photographers and many good
photographers really work hard for those
assignments but I've been fortunate some
good ones have come along you invited me
on one of the Bay Bridge and you know
that was an adventure I I don't love
although you might be surprised I don't
love Heights yeah this was a really
interesting I invited him to walk up the
cables of the on the Golden Gate Bridge
with the bay lights folks thinking like
after seeing all of his photographs
going well this guy's got this no
problem and he gets there that mornings
like by the way I'm super afraid of
heights we're about to walk the cables
of the Bay Bridge people would walk the
cables of the Bay Bridge no problem
that's about a third okay you know it
turned out to be you know this is the
say yes to adventure because I really
don't mind actually the Navy I've been a
bunch of places but I really just don't
like Heights
and you know the Bay Bridge cable is a
cable where if you fall you'll be
dangling there in front of you know all
of this traffic and and you know I
thought about it and you know Sofia and
I talked about it a little bit and and
you know you got to say yes you got to
say yes to all of these adventures and
I'm so glad he didn't you know the
quickest way to get over your fear of
heights is climbing the cables kind of
the scariest part is climbing onto the
cable at the very beginning by the
roadway to me okay what that's scary
part number one scary part number two is
when you're at the top and it's like
really steep and the guys trying to hook
his little hook onto your right where he
kept missing and I was like falling I'm
like come on I have a video of this well
I thought it was very interesting how
you said yes to it immediately but then
you know the morning of it
you actually admitted your fears and so
but still owner abilities all the rage
[Laughter]
and things like I mean getting on to the
you to did that be was that because of
your history I guess we haven't really
talked about one of the companies you
started with military comm you had a
military history and you were moving
into entrepreneurship and that seemed
like a crossroads but then you also had
been not a pilot but a navigator with
the Navy was that all fitting into all
of that I mean it's it's a really
special thing to be asked to go up in a
u2 and I mean the technical reason I
went up as a journalist but I was asked
to do it you know I actually gave a talk
leadership talked to the military
military that comes really early in with
the internet and social media and the
military and I was giving this talk to a
bunch of generals and one of them came
up to me he said well if you come to my
base at Beale I'll get you up in at you
too and I thought he was kidding I mean
I didn't realize the u2 was still flying
and I had that great moment it's kind of
a sad moment a little bit because you
know you ever have these experiences
where you feel well I'm never gonna get
to do anything like this again I felt
great when I saw the Tesla in space I
thought okay well maybe there's a chance
in my life that I'll get to go back up
and I also want to touch base on this
this thing where you seem to you seem to
turn the camera in the opposite
direction in a way of the the postcard
image to see the reaction that other
people are having and to catch the
moment that they're having with that and
there's wonder if you could say more
about that because I think that's it
that's a non-intuitive thing everyone's
always got their pictures pointed at the
pyramids and to turn it away I'll never
forget when I went to see the shuttle
launch
I remember the general who was in charge
of the launch said you know don't take
any videos of this or getting yet we got
that covered here at NASA just
experience it and it we happen to be
where the families were of the
astronauts and I remember be cheering
the launch and turning around and seeing
just tears streaming down all these
people's faces they were clearly having
a very different launch experience than
I was and I wish now that I captured
that moment and so when you said when
you talked about turning the camera
around it was you've answered your own
question
I mean it's interesting because I don't
know about all of you but I am drawn to
take those pictures and begun I mean
there it's just so beautiful and you
know there's nothing wrong with taking
those photographs there are great
photographs but it will never be a
special photograph I mean it might be
special reminds you of your memories but
the really great photographs are the
other things and you know it's it's not
straightforward to look for those other
things but that's where all of the the
joy is I'll tell you something else it
kind of personally and that is that
everyone can take and there's
photographers out there that take
pictures way better than my photographs
of like landscape and animals and I'd
rather I'm not competing but I'd rather
take my own take on these things that
are not easily comparable it's even like
my life as an investor or a entrepreneur
I just never felt like it like I was
like other entrepreneurs I just always
had I was doing it was like a
photographer and I was doing other
things so maybe my approach to life is
to not do it the way other people are
doing it because I don't want to be
compared to them I'd like it to be more
unique and I know they can do better
than me so and I mean you mentioned
early on kind of in passing that gear
doesn't matter yet I know you're a total
gearhead and you know there's it doesn't
matter and it does I think it's kind of
like any technicals activity or sport I
just wonder if you can expand on the
earth your theory of gear not on my
shoulder there's you know the good devil
and the angel and they're like buy more
gear don't buy any more gear but I'm
working here I just I'm moving and I
just got rid of 90% of my camera
equipment it was a lot of camera
equipment you still have more than
anybody and you know when I came back
from Antarctica
I took 40,000 photographs in January 40
nautical not counting the the film
40,000 digital photographs and I was
processing every day for eight hours a
day for four weeks and don't ever ever
do that it's a giant mistake and while I
was doing that I was going on some trips
and I refused to bring my real camera
because I didn't want to
to that queue and I use my iPhone is
amazing I was able to capture good
photographs and really good photographs
and I you know and I'd never done that
but I didn't really use my iPhone ever
and when people bring out their phone
I'm really kind of a little put off
because I don't feel like they're taking
good photographs and what I knew
intellectually I now know emotionally
which is if you use those techniques we
talked about which is really slowing
down and making the best photograph you
can it doesn't matter the gear right
you're right does it matter a little bit
type of like yeah I mean if you're in
Safari your iPhone is useless I mean you
can basically get like lots of specks in
the distance so in certain circumstances
the gear does matter but from most
photography you know keV I tried to give
Kevin a Kelly or Kevin Kelly a the
camera I'm like Kevin take my camera
he's like no I'm happy with my camera
yeah his point at you say Kevin is also
a better photographer than me which I
also hate you guys actually I mean I
think some of the moments that you
capture remind me of each other and so I
think there's it's very much there's
like there's a connection but you know
for all of you I mean if you were gonna
have one major takeaway from today
around your own photography remember I
said you know you're the documentarians
of your own lives when you use your
iPhone or whatever you're using don't
take two seconds on the picture take ten
seconds
frame the picture slow down beside what
you want and take two pictures and then
there's a second part of that and that
is make sure you take that photo you
process it and you store it someplace
else because I hate to tell you and you
already know this
iCloud doesn't work you're gonna lose
all of those photos eventually you're
gonna do a backup you're gonna change
phones you have to spend the time to
preserve these memories and that's even
beyond like the cloud or Google you
probably have to do what Kevin doesn't
print the book you know eventually if
it's not on paper it's probably in
trouble but if you all take that extra
second I mean how many photos do you
need of anything you just
one photograph so just take a little bit
of time look I've been shooting for 20
years I just learned that lesson with my
phone which is take a few more seconds
so yes we're gonna open it up to
questions after this one and that the
one question I always have when I come
across you and you you're in here or in
the battery or something and you seemed
completely unjaded by the world that you
live in and always that the happiest
person in Silicon Valley and is yet you
you know you went through a company that
nearly failed that you then kind of
turned around and and all of those
things we're really bad where where does
the happiness come from where are you
finding that that's a good question it's
it's a kind of perennial question are we
born with it or is it environmental I
can't speak to the first part I think
I'm generally kind of a happy person but
you know I I just love people and I you
know I find everyone endlessly
entertaining and when I engage with
people I really want to just have a good
time with them and talk to them and help
them and support and that's our mutually
reinforcing kind of experience and
that's the way I live my life and it's a
life connected to other people and it
works for me yes first question you you
mentioned that you're gonna keep going
back to America forever until you pass
away what that's a good question
um you know the the extrapolation of
that question is when you keep going
back to the same place you know is it
worth it's expensive place to go it's
far away
takes a lot of time well you know
there's there's two parts of this one
part is probably just the experience I'm
just very
maybe again because of my experiences
I'm just very happy in these kind
remote places a little bit alone
a little bit reflective so I love that
experience you know people go to the spa
over and over again you know I this is
my spot to go to Antarctica but the
thing I love most of all are the people
so I like nature it's great penguins are
fabulous I get that angle penguin
pictures all the time but you know what
I didn't talk about was I was in a tight
camp with 40 workers and there's
seasonal workers and these people some
of them have PhDs some of them didn't go
to college but what they choose to do is
spend their life in this little summer
camp in this incredibly remote and
hostile place and to observe them and
you know they work seven days a week
probably 12 hours a day to observe them
and be part of that community and
photograph that community and it is just
fascinating for me I just love that and
there's so much of that in remote places
where people are living different lives
and and I was saying different realities
so I feel like I've only scratched the
surface think about all the weird people
that work at McMurdo you know like
there's a really cool documentaries that
have been done on these people and they
keep coming back and I love it I mean
we're Hertz like did that great movie
which was the call to edge and edge of
where all the world's much really great
so I guess it's just to tell Store
stories of the people that are there so
a related question from the live stream
from Carter as we're starting to lose
the grand ice of the planet and these
next few generations may be the last to
know real glaciers or the ice cap the
way we understand it now what would you
hope that people notice about ice ice
now the ice we have now while there's
still time
that's a good question you know the
question I often get that's sort of like
that question is what have I observed
relating to climate change or warming
and the truth is in the interior not
much there's so much ice it's so white
it's so vast there's you know miles of
ice you just don't notice it at the
North Pole way more noticeable right the
multi-year sea ice
is really thin I took my jacket off at
the North Pole you keep seeing all these
art they love they're the favorite
article is you know it's it's warmer at
the North Pole than Paris that's a place
that if you don't get to soon enough
it's gonna be a problem it's a huge
challenge in the north the South is a
little bit harder what's happened is the
the frozen edge of Antarctica is a lot
smaller than it used to be but it's not
that noticeable and honestly as the
climate warms further you may see even
more spectacular ice because more pieces
of the Shelf will break off so I think
it's not gonna be something that's
really that observable and Antarctica
other than you may see more ice but then
in the North it really matters I mean to
me the the shoot I want to do is these
great northern communities the Inuit
communities the people in Greenland
whose life was built on the edge right
and that's changing and boy that's gonna
be in our lifetime the it's an
incredibly dramatic change and the I was
I was also strict on a trip to small
bard and I went kind of for a technical
reason to see how the vault itself was
built because we're building millennial
structures as well but I also think it's
there's something about those places
that attract weird people hmm and you
mentioned the ones that are that are at
these camps but also the ones that live
perennial II at the highest or lowest
latitudes I think are they they're just
all characters they're all they're very
strange reason oh yeah
the most interesting people on the
planet yeah I mean did you stay at
Maryann's polar rig I am is here we we
didn't stay there but we went for some
drinks right it's like this woman who
just like started stacking double wides
in the middle of Svalbard and became a
hotel I didn't tell you one thing about
my experience in Antarctica it was
different this time that's related to
small bar to Maryann's and that is when
I was at the camp there were two reality
television shows being filmed at the
same time
the most popular reality show in Japan
and one from Korea and they're all there
to like have these weird experiences and
tell the story of these unusual people
and it's the same thing BBC did one in
Svalbard it's that you know about the
ice people I don't their super
interesting
I love being around them I'm probably
one of them I aspire to be as cool and
weird as these people and some of them
you see in Svalbard because you know
it's seasonal work I was saying that
people some people came up to me and
said well you know it's pretty cool
you've been to these places and you've
been to Antarctica and the North Pole
and and it's very humbling I'm looking
at the tent camp in the back I'm it's
very humbling to be there because of the
people you meet are way more
accomplished than you are I was saying I
went to a talk my friend Ramsay who's
here from this woman Alison Levine who's
been who climbed Everest twice and you
know she's got a book and she's on a
tour and she's really inspiring I was
having lunch with three people and
Antarctica three random people between
them they'd summited Everest 30 times
they don't have any book you know so
like I you know what can I say I'm I
should say a Lee this incredible company
there's the only company that can take
people into the interior of Antarctica
they support people like Yasu who was
skied to the pole like Robert Swan who
just you know with his sons again ski to
the pole they call people like me or
maybe some of you who go down there that
live on the ice in a tent eating who
knows a lot using bags for you know what
they call us
soft clients oops I shouldn't say that
because we're not the tough people
the tough people are the people that do
the other stuff so I I feel very humbled
I don't feel like I've done very much
I've just had been lucky enough to go to
these unusual places and I mean the
other thing that was curious to me about
suave art is that what I didn't realize
before going is the the amount that the
the arctic and I suspect the Antarctic
is a politicized place that almost all
of the terrain around the Arctic is
claimed by many many countries
small part being one of them and have
you have some of your invites crossed
over that that you were having and
negotiate those politics um you're on a
Russian nice nuclear-powered icebreakers
yeah well there's a there's a guy named
Michael McDowell and Michael McDowell is
the like father of adventure tourism so
he created quark he created which is the
company that rents the nuclear
icebreaker that goes to Russia he opened
up the Antarctic with all that you
remember the original ships they were
all Russian ships he dives on the
Titanic he's one of the founders of
space adventures basically if you
reverse engineer his but he's figured
out it was it was how to get access to
Russian semi military equipment during
the fall of the Soviet Union and that's
how all of these things I mean oh like
even I went to Baikonur I did space
training I've docked in the simulator
you know how is it possible that I could
do all of these things it's because in
Russia you can pay and go to space I
mean it's really amazing your specific
question is has it caused me some
challenges well there's one area where
it's kind of tricky and that's an
Antarctica because there's the Antarctic
Treaty and the Antarctic Treaty is a
heavily negotiated document I can
remember how many signatories but many
things are covered like drone I was
flying a drone drone usage you know we
had the Korean crew lost a drone in the
mountain under Antarctic Treaty they
have to you they have to man an
expedition to recover the drone how
stupid is I mean to risk a lot of human
lives to recover a little piece of metal
didn't seem like the brightest idea to
me but this is navigating all of these
geopolitical rules and a lot of those
rules weren't designed just to protect
the environment they're also designed to
advantage one country or another and
those countries are actively working to
do that the Arctic is the big deal right
now and the Arctic is the big deal
because of shipping and because of oil
and ladies and gentlemen the Russians
are playing varsity ball and we're not
even on the field all of those ships are
real I think we have two operable
icebreakers so I went to a talk George
Shultz gave in San Francisco
the Chief of Naval Operations was there
the CEO of the Navy like six people
showed up it's like you know the former
Secretary of State the head of the Navy
talking about the national security
threat over the Arctic and we're just
not prepared to operate there and it's
now open to military equipment and
mining and people doing lots of stuff
that they shouldn't be doing and the
Russians are right there next person
what do you think of selfies as an art
form as a photographic art form I mean
your face selfie was amazing but it's
definitely a more rarefied selfie than
most people take that's that's a tricky
question the selfie stick is super
annoying can we agree that that I don't
know what it is about the selfie stick
that's so annoying but when you see one
you really feel offended maybe you're
gonna get I was just yeah no I'm you're
gonna get hit by ride across the Golden
Gate Bridge and when the bikes and the
humans are on the same side in the
morning it's most dangerous thing as
randomly someone's gonna go to the side
while you're going by them at 30 miles
an hour yeah I don't know so I don't
really like selfie sticks although they
kind of work I'm a used one once and I
thought it worked you brought one on our
trip up the campus of the Bay Bridge and
they are embarrassing because I have
like a GoPro and I was ready to shoot
all this stuff I'm you know I'm okay
with all kinds of photography people are
always going on and about you shouldn't
take postcards or you shouldn't
photograph these people or you shouldn't
do selfies you know if it makes you feel
good and it helps you document your life
that's great people's tolerance for
photos of yourself over and over and
over again post I mean some people like
that but I think that there's lower
power especially an Instagram you know I
do see people and their feed always
posting photos of themselves it's okay
so I guess I think it's I think it's
okay but I don't know I hope for each of
you to or to challenge each of you to
try to take other parts although I will
say some of that is good because you
know you're taking photos not just for
yourself but for your families and for
future generations so some photos of you
in these places I think are kind of a
nice thing and I try to do that I try to
occasionally get a photo of me doing
something interest
mm-hmm this Stuart brand is on the live
stream says hi and wants to add what you
were talking to the generals about you
know it's always stored in Kevin with
these questions I was warned that okay
um so something you all don't know about
me this is the first time I've ever
taken my photographs and put them
together like this it's it's quite a
daunting task to take 20 years of
photography and narrow it down it was a
10-year journey but 20 years of
photography
I've given lots of talks and usually
what I talk about is having failed as an
entrepreneur and the challenges that I
had and at military comm which could be
a talk for another time you know Anne
and I who's my co-founder of military we
started this company like it's kind of
like Facebook in 1999 and we raised a
lot of money and we ran out of money
when the bubble burst and I got fired as
a CEO and I swam for six months thinking
about all the mistakes I made I got to
come back to the company and to shut it
down essentially and Anne and I were
able to turn it around just the last
minute I mean we were really in trouble
and I learned a few things that I had
never learned in my time in the Navy or
in business school about leadership and
so what that talk was about was some of
those lessons and it was also a talk
about how large bureaucratic
organizations can innovate and I know
that's something we all talk about but
you know in the military my favorite
people were either about to be promoted
or fired because they were challenging
the system and it's true in all of our
lives we see those people they do things
that you know aren't what other people
are doing and sometimes it's there's
high friction but occasion of those
people do something that matters and
organizations like the military or large
companies they need to figure out how to
protect some of those people so I was
talking to the generals specifically
about when you get I mean I by the way I
was that person in the military one of
the reasons I got out I I just would
call this now I did I did well in the
Navy but I was a weirdo I wasn't like
other people in the military and I had a
commanding officer that supported me
and protected me and appreciated it but
I felt like at any moment I could get a
normal community officer that might
think I was a weirdo and maybe shouldn't
be in the military
so I was talking about the obligation
that these generals might have to some
of those people there were a little
different than other people yes yeah
well Stuart is one of the other people
who started his career in the military
as well Stuart Stuart came to visit us
at military comm I think in 2000 or 2001
long time ago next question and all your
adventures edges of the world what do
you regret besides not looking at the
film on the camera and the projector um
I'll tell you one thing about my own
photography you know in the back screens
they're playing some like images of mine
and it's difficult for me to look at my
work from more than six or seven years
ago I don't think it's very good I mean
I think I was lucky and was able to
capture some good images but I really
didn't know what I was doing as a
photographer and I took a moment to kind
of acknowledge my mentor Sam Abel and I
took a class was I right I mean I've
been working as a photographer for a
long time and I randomly took a class
with Sam not thinking that I needed to
take any class and it really transformed
the way I see the world and my approach
and so what I regret is that I didn't
have the skills necessary to capture
those incredible moments the way I would
like to so I have hundreds of thousands
of photographs that could have been a
lot better so that's my great regret and
one of the things that you you ended up
doing was being the dali lama's
photographer for his tour and the United
States can tell a little bit about how
that came to be and what that was like
um okay well I I was just his
photographer for three days when he was
at MIT and it was the best and worst
photographic experience of my life
and it came about by someone you know
and someone whose photograph I showed
tonight Tenzin and so Tenzin runs the
Dalai Lama Center for Ethics at MIT he
spoke here a few weeks ago I spoke here
and I think you guys were used that same
photo that I did I just
and I knew Tenzin from another world
just a well who doesn't know a mom could
you know he's just a monk that I know
and they needed a photographer and he
asked if I would be the Dalai Lama's
photographer and it was really this
super interesting experience so I'll
share a couple things about it one just
is about the Dalai Lama in general you
know when you meet someone I'm Buddhist
and when you meet someone that you
admire and respect a lot from afar it's
a dangerous thing it's risky
right they say don't meet your you know
don't meet the rock stars you love
because you might be disappointed well I
was this close to the diorama for three
days I was in his hotel room I traveled
around everywhere with him I watched him
very carefully he is as good or better
than you could imagine he cares deeply
about everyone equally right the people
I mean we together and a lot of security
people and some political to that and or
political people from the Tibetan
government-in-exile we've got lots of
people we met really famous rock stars
we met business people and we also met
like it was a woman you know so imagine
we're at the Charles know talent if
you've ever stay there in Cambridge and
you know he's got four rooms or
something it's not like the Saudi prince
where they rent the whole hotel and so
there's like 20 defense or 20 State
Department security people with like
guns a bunch of monks and this young
woman walks out of her room and there's
the Dalai Lama standing there and all of
these security people and she's just
looking at him like what is going on
here and you know he treated her the
same way he treated to stay right he's
that guy and it was incredible the hard
part for me was you know it was
basically like this you wanted to have
these like very quiet moments with this
person you admire but he's the super
celebrity rock star so everywhere we
went they were like throngs of people
the
celebrities were not that great I mean
you know my impression of that
experience with some of these people was
he almost felt like these people had
everything in their lives but they were
still unhappy and we're hoping as
holiness would give them something I
don't want to read too much into it but
that you could see that they wanted
something and that wasn't the pleasant
experience for me I didn't enjoy that
but it was a really cool experience you
know when and when you get a photo
posted to the dalai lama's website you
get like a million people he's a cool
guy there's only two places by the way
here I think we'd like to have it on as
a project to establish a moon base well
I'm gonna solve 50% of that I agree to
be the photographer okay great yeah all
right are we good yeah no I mean I think
the I mean long nosed foray into space
so far has been the actually the rosetta
disk which is right behind you in that
cabinet there one of those was launched
on the on the space mission to the comet
[Music]
was it that was the original target then
it got changed by good 67p was the one
that but and then it took 10 years to
get there and then it eventually they
crash landed it on the comment so now
there's this this funny disc with
thousands of languages on it but it's
the funny thing is that it's now be made
us a magnet for people who are sending
weird things into space and they want to
know about it and so or they want
something like all this language content
to go so we now
getting asked this question for datasets
and most recently the what the company
that if you that had the Asthma
Foundation series in the Tesla Roadster
on that last launch we now partnered
with and they're taking some of their
content for their next mission but
that's as far as we've gotten commitment
to do it right away
ya know it's not a commitment to do it
right now I work we're working on it
how are we doing for time I didn't
actually bring any time devices with me
hey there alright so we're gonna we're
gonna wrap it up here but I did want to
ask one last question the there is an
incredible generosity that I have
encountered with you and your images the
way you've given image is you take
pictures and effectively release them as
near as I can tell at least you have to
me but I what's your model like you
you said you became a photographer in
2008 you have this insane generosity
with your work
what's the how how did you arrive at the
model that you're doing and what is
there do you get paid for any of it is
there any what is how does that work
it's the worst business model of all
time the worst now um well let's see I
do make a little bit of money people buy
prints from the website and some
companies I can't mention have licensed
libraries to use and like phones and
computers Google if you like the
chromecast you can see my pictures but
the truth is I'm able to do this because
of my life as an entrepreneur so I
didn't make a lot of money but I made
enough money so that I can spend time in
my small place and focus on photography
and honestly I'd rather just give you
than buy it and I don't you know I don't
fully understand my own psychology but
basically I live in the world of taking
photographs and giving those photographs
away I creative commons-licensed almost
all of my photographs and that's the
that's the reward for me the reward is
that
people are happier because I've given
them an image or I've captured something
that mattered in their lives and you
know maybe in the final analysis I'll
think that I should have worked at the
business of photography more but vanilla
counts for me I mean I've taken
portraits of so many people in this room
and you know I'd like to think that it
made their lives a little bit better and
that some people in the future will look
at those photographs and appreciate them
well I think for somebody who believes
in karma you've been creating amazing
karma I want to give you a loan now
challenging I mean more portly I just
want to thank you for the generosity of
the images that you've given to us in
the world and for making our here bigger
every day
[Applause]
[Music]